as you might have noticed the marvel
cinematic universe is big and getting
bigger these days however the sheer
level of talent that's involved in
bringing all those superheroes and
villains on screens both big and small
is even bigger the list of academy award
winners who have either appeared in an
mcu movie or that are set to do so in
the near future is currently comprised
of no less than 26 actors according to
ign that number should give you a rough
idea about the overall caliber of talent
behind the many marvel characters to
grace the silver screen of course there
are still plenty of great actors who
haven't joined the mcu in any capacity
yet and fans are often speculating about
the next big name addition to the
sprawling mega franchise he might not
have an oscar to his name yet but keanu
reeves is one of the biggest names who
tend to come up in such conversations
he's easily one of the biggest action
movie actors who has yet to attach their
names to a marvel studios project which
seems all the more glaring when you
remember that his two most famous roles
neo in the matrix movies and the titular
character of the john wick franchise are
essentially superheroes themselves he
was the one you sent to kill the
pokemon reeves and the mcu seem like a
perfect fit but is there any chance for
this match made in tentpole movie heaven
to ever happen now the actor has finally
weighed in on whether he'd ever join the
marvel cinematic universe in a video
interview with esquire while fielding
questions about roles from throughout
his career reeves had a surprisingly
straightforward answer in response to
esquire asking him outright whether or
not a marvel film role might be in his
future first of all reeves noted that
the word universe is starting to fail to
adequately account for the true scope of
the mcu saying isn't it bigger than a
universe it's almost like a multiverse
it's a marvel verse however he
ultimately didn't dodge the question
about becoming a part of that world
himself saying it would be an honor he
then spoke to the quality of talent
involved behind the scenes of many of
marvel's flagship projects saying
there's some really amazing directors
and visionaries and they're doing
something that no one's really ever done
it's special in that sense in terms of
the scale the ambition the production so
it would be cool to be a part of that
all in all it appears that reeves is at
the very least not yet a part of an mcu
project or if he is he's clearly not at
liberty to share the news with the
public yet nevertheless he appears to be
about as open as an actor could be to
the prospect of joining marvel's
multi-billion dollar franchise meaning
that his eventual mcu debut remains a
distinct enticing possibility people
keep asking if i'm back
and i haven't really had an answer
but now yeah
i'm taken on back
it's fascinating that keanu reeves
actually addressed the mcu rumors and
doubly so because he didn't shoot them
down after all speculation of his
involvement in some upcoming mcu
projects has been running rampant for
years now take the rumor that made the
rounds in march 2020 for example it
suggested that reeves might become the
mcu incarnation of ghost writer the
skull-faced flaming motorcycle rider
might be an interesting choice seeing as
a version of the character has already
made an appearance in the mcu adjacent
agents of shield portrayed by gabriel
luna though reeves would probably
portray the johnny blaise version of the
character which was memorably played by
nicholas cage and the decidedly non-mcu
2007 movie ghost rider and its buckwild
sequel ghost rider spirit of vengeance a
recent looper pole meanwhile determined
that fans want reeves to portray the
superhuman adam warlock that role of
course ultimately went to midsummer star
will poulter but there's plenty of
reason to assume that the rumor mill
will keep turning for quite a while
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie rumors are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]